let's go next to our caller from the
7:05 area code who's calling today from
7:05 it's actually what's up I would
miss Pierce fue
so in David Epstein almonds are
counterfeit and yet my trans commerce
plant such telling or not you have seen
the peel is invisible
what is he but the whole Russian
connection this obscene such bring more
angry just basically recruiting people
Russia to Batman to control with us
it's just like when strong sources tell
me
Steve I have no idea what you're talking
about and I don't know if it's the
connection or what you're saying but a
Dershowitz and Russia a conspiracy
involving Berkowitz in Russia
well Dershowitz Epstein yes he was one
of the guys that used to know that
that's what is disappointing you know
going to his Island didn't gather out
some and trample is one of one of the
people who hung up as well so like you
know was as various Todd crane
conspiracy well sure that all these
judges everything upfront has been a
point but they all have video of them
having sex with underage girls and like
William Bonner Francis maybe they've got
he wasn't okay that is quite a wait I
wouldn't be able to say anything else
about it because I just I just have no
idea but let's let people simmer on that
a little bit and see see if it tickles
their fancy and if that strikes anybody
as a real possibility
okay that does it for today's calls on
that note we will take a quick break
much more show coming
sorry to everybody that I did not get to
but many more opportunities including
during our impeachment livestreams to
get on the phone with me